muito muito obrigado a todos também é um
grande prazer estar aqui com
que estaria responsável
agradecer a honra e costa ea organização
do táxi seu preço com vida
a meu ver marcela essa psicóloga clínica
e só investigadora da universidade
coimbrã e vim aqui hoje para vos falar
nada antes que pudessem exatamente da
revolução da compaixão e em que medida é
que com paixão pode ajudar a que nos
tornemos seres humanos mais mais com
isso
esta imagem é uma imagem do canvas o
happy café em londres em 2015 no
contexto maquiagem trabalho que eu fiz
assinava seguir até lá pelo novo café
ensinar o café fluence e conhecer este
café pra ver um chá eo café um café
muito engraçado e em todas as paredes
como vocês podem ver na imagem os preços
são cobertas de perguntas e as pessoas
eles são convidados a responder com
diversos tops que existem as suas portas
mais variadas perguntas nomeadamente
qual é o teu lugar fiz quase não as
minhas memórias da sua infância pode se
dizer alguma coisa o seu mais novo
queria e foi com alguma surpresa que na
mesa em que senta aí é esta pergunta
estava em frente à mesa não sentem que
está à venda qual é o teu super coelho e
foi com espanto que um pula perceber que
alguém tinha identificado como seu super
poder algo que também eu partilhava mas
que ao longo de toda a minha vida nunca
tinha visto dessa forma eu consigo fazer
com que as minhas mãos transpira em
basta crer
esta é a síntese do meu corpo transpirar
das mãos a foi algo que ao longo de
muito tempo da minha vida eu vi como um
feito e que em alguns momentos da minha
vida me fez sentir diferente aí
envergonhada e neste momento a este
momento foi aumentar o valor para mim
porque neste momento eu compreendi a e
percebi que não só existe alguém
a guerra existem outras pessoas que
partilhavam essa mesma característica
física que eu mas existe alguém no mundo
havia esta característica física como um
superpoder e nesse momento eu percebi
porque é que esta minha vulnerabilidade
desta ele ou sem crise do meu corpo que
eu não escolhi era também um superpoder
e pude ver o quanto ela me ensinou ao
longo da minha vida há acerca da
importância nós aceitarmos e sobrados as
nossas imperfeições nos trataram de com
amabilidade e mandada nos sentirmos a
site aí compreendidos pelos outros a
nossa volta é aprendermos aturar lidar
com quem como desagradável e termos a
coragem para lidar com aquilo que é
difícil da nossa vida
mesmo com as nossas idiossincrasias e
facto as nossas vulnerabilidades
enquanto seres humanos é que o que é o
nosso sofrimento enquanto seres humanos
têm este poder de nos ensinar a ser uma
das pessoas mais compassivos para
conosco para com os outros porque o fato
é na escuridão da nossa humanidade comum
no nosso sofrimento enquanto humanos que
compaixão pode ter cheiro choldra diz
que é compaixão não é uma relação entre
o curador e ferido é uma relação entre
iguais somente quando conhecemos bem a
nossa própria escuridão
podemos estar presente com a escuridão
dos outros e para essa minha experiência
pessoal que acompanhou a luta da minha
vida e isto é no início do meu percurso
enquanto investigadora psicóloga e
dediquei-me estudar a vergonha ea
experiência de vergonha
interessante não foi pra casa e nesta
estas investigações com uma das coisas
que demonstraram foi criado factos
experiências de vergonha podem ter um
impacto muito fácil nas nossas vidas mas
que esse impacto negativo não vai estar
que os preços da companhia podem ter
pode ser enfraquecido
pessoas sentirem compreendidas e
apoiadas pelas outras pessoas à sua
volta e se elas próprias forem capazes
de ser compatíveis para consigo mesmo
então a questão a que tem nos últimos
anos
direcionar guiado a minha vida pessoal
mas também a minha vida profissional é
esta fraca encararmos as nossas
vulnerabilidades o nosso sofrimento com
compaixão pode ser visto como um
superpoder humano capaz de promover
nosso bem estar
o nosso conhecimento enquanto pessoas e
que pode mesmo ter revolucionado o nosso
mundo interno e externo
mas afinal o que é estudar com paixão a
não existe uma definição única e
universal com paixão mas eu subscrevo a
idéia do que é compaixão ea idéia foi
proposta por dalai lama e foi adaptar vá
para um autor muito em si nesta área é
chamada por iogurte e e e ela diz essa
pressão diz que compaixão é
sensibilidade ao sofrimento no próprio
nos outros com profundo compromisso para
tentar aliviar com o primeiro
e ao contrário daquilo que muitas
pessoas pensam quando pensando a palavra
compaixão é compaixão não é pena não é o
mesmo que amor não é ser autoindulgente
não é ser fraco não é apenas ser
simpático cãozinho não é submetermos a
vontade das outras pessoas nem é sequer
queremos nos livrar da dor e do
sofrimento não a compaixão não é nada
disso
a compaixão é sinônimo de coragem e de
um profundo compromisso com o nosso
estádio é esta capacidade nós notamos o
sofrimento em nós e nas outras pessoas e
ao mesmo tempo se nos movidos por uma
intenção de fazer o que está ao nosso
alcance para tentar aliviar e 1º e
sofrimento e da compaixão é mais do que
este desejo ser útil e ajudar
ela envolve uma profunda intenção de não
provocar o mal é não provocar
não magoar os outros ou nós mesmos do
propósito mas afinal quais são as
origens evolucionárias a da compaixão
o tema deste teve e be leva bucha como é
que viu esta nossa capacidade para
servir com passivos em quatro anos
a história é mais ou menos assim a
durante muitos milhões de anos os seres
vivos que evitavam no nosso planeta não
precisavam de cuidados à nascença
estas duas vezes ainda hoje por exemplo
elas rompem os seus ovos imagem dos
ninhos e juntamente com seus irmãos e
irmãs correm para o mar
nascem aos milhares e não precisam de
cuidados
contudo a maioria das tartarugas bebés
não sobreviveu primeiro dia vida ou à
comida procuradores estima se que cerca
de 98% das tartarugas que nascem não
chegam à vida adulta humanos não são
como o verso e apesar de também ao serem
muito fofinhos toca rasteiro mas venci
os seres humanos são os mais indefesos
esta é minha filha a maria clara e tal
como ela todos os seres humanos quando
nascem são altamente vulneráveis e
precisam de muitos cuidados para
sobreviver
eles não sabem alimentar sozinhos nem
conseguem andar ou falar para os
primeiros anos de vida precisam de colo
do conforto de serem amados do tema vem
com quem brincar e hoje em dia cada vez
mais só sai no ninho já em adultos as 20
30 e às vezes 40 anos é e esta nossa
capacidade para cuidar para confortar
para a calma para estarmos atentos às
necessidades do outro ser e tentaram
responder essas sociedades de formar
quadros para apoiar o crescimento do
outro ser e preparar estou torcer para
os desafios de uma vida independente é
uma motivação inata está inscrita nos
nossos genes humanos e que nós
portugueses com outros mamíferos
e esta motivação para cuidar esta nossa
capacidade para cuidar e viu a cerca de
120 milhões de anos atrás com os nossos
antepassados mamíferos importante é
muito antiga que está inscrita em áreas
muito primitivas do nosso cérebro e por
isso é que nós amigos nós temos aos
miados nós temos em mãos muito reduzidos
mas a taxa de sobrevivência torcer nas
redes de amigos e nos mans em cima como
sabemos é outra estratégia é muito
diferente das tartarugas e drag queens
para garantir essa vivência e nós
enquanto humanos também os próprios
bebés vai em bonitos bem preparados e
evoluíram é capacidade para eles citaram
cuidar dos anjos próprio pv são capazes
de procurar a proximidade da proteção eo
cuidado dos seus pais tentaram localizá
los e ficarem perto de anos e são
fisiologicamente rotulados e acalmado
pelos pais e pela presença dos seus
progenitores e portanto a é compaixão
emerge assim festa combinação entre esta
motivação para cuidar muito primitiva
que nós partilhamos com outros mamíferos
e desta nossa também capacidade para
responder a sinais de cuidar por parte
dos outros e evitar esses cuidados e nós
enquanto mamíferos também evoluímos para
viver e para prosperar dentro de
famílias e pequenos grupos e facto
outros desafios e funcionários ao longo
da nossa evolução enquanto espécie
contribuíram para a evolução desse
comportamento descuidado como por
exemplo a importância de sermos vistos
como é aliados como amigos como
parceiros sexuais atrativos como sendo
visto com pessoas capazes estamos
relações afetivas e termos de
comportamento de cooperação
é por isso que os nossos comportamentos
cuidado é não se restringem às relações
entre pais filhos mas estendem-se
relações do nosso grupo social é mais
alargado e facto esta é nossa nós
nós somos a espécie mais social todas a
e é o fato nós temos capaz de temos
relações positivas com os outros
temos uma extraordinária vantagem
evolucionária é e por isso mesmo fez
acompanhar de um conjunto de drásticas
mudanças no cérebro sobretudo ao nível
do nosso córtex pré frontal e no
desenvolvimento de um conjunto de
competências cognitivas avançadas que
são únicas específicas nos mais e
portanto é que o que distinga é
compaixão e cuidar não humano que nós
podemos observar nos outros amigos é que
o facto da compaixão recruta este
conjunto de competências cognitivas
complexas aquilo irão muito mais
recentemente na nossa história
evolucionária cerca de dois milhões de
anos atrás e essas competências
cognitivas são a nossa capacidade para
imaginar para recordar passava para
pensar acerca do futuro para pensarmos
acerca das nossas próprias emoções e
pensamentos para imaginar o que os
outros podem estar a pensar ou a sentir
para termos uma consciência e para ser
capaz de sentir uma simpatia por tanta
compaixão é mais do que o simples cuidar
porque nós humanos somos capazes de usar
a nossa inteligência social emocional
o nosso saber consciente e nossa
intensidade para dirigir o nosso
comportamento de cuidado de novas formas
é compaixão envolve esta intenção
consciente de ajudar alguém que está em
sofrimento e por tanta compaixão em
termos evolucionários emerge da
combinação entre esta motivação para
cuidar e estas competências cognitivas
avançadas estão inscritas nas partes
mais centros do nosso cérebro e este
nosso cérebro evoluído é facto muito
complexa e desta complexidade nasce
muito daquilo que é o nosso sofrimento e
os problemas que nós vemos no nosso
mundo hoje em dia é mesmo lamenta esta
nossa mente que é capaz de cuidar dos
outros de proteger os mais fracos de
lutar pela paz e pela justiça e inventar
curas para doenças de fazer a música
criar a escrever poesia e da inventar as
mais inacreditáveis tecnologias como as
que nos permitem estar aqui hoje ter
essa conversa é mesma mente responsável
que você quer hans pelo tribunal smo
pelo racismo pelo imóvel pela
escravatura pela tortura
esta meta que têm estas competências
incríveis que nos definem quanto humanos
é mesma mente que não gerencia waddoups
antistress iluminação vergonha e
autocrítica e sei então o nosso cérebro
nossa mente é facto capaz do melhor e do
pior nível individual ea nível social
isso é nossa mente existem as sementes e
as potencialidades para aquilo que quer
e escuridão da nossa humanidade mas
também para que o que o que mais
luminoso existe na nossa humanidade
quais é que são as sementes as
potencialidades e os poderes da nossa
mente que nós queremos motivar porque
graças a neuroplasticidade os nossos
cérebros
a ciência mostra os que efetivamente nós
podemos treinar a nossa mente para
aprendermos praticaremos incorporarmos
terminar as qualidades como a compaixão
e quais é que são essas qualidades que
nós podemos treinar e cultivada na nossa
mente para aprendermos a ser mais
compassivos e a primeira essa teoria
ou seja desenvolvermos a nossa
compreensão do nosso conhecimento acerca
do que é isto sermos seres humanos
acerca do funcionamento da nossa mente
da forma como contexto social e nós
vivemos nos modos molda e acerca de como
é que podemos ajudar forma sábia e hotel
em segundo lugar nós precisamos de força
e coragem para enfrentar e para lidar
com o sofrimento
gilberto diz que a compaixão e coragem
para
ser a realizada da experiência humana
porque a experiência humana é facto
muitas vezes dolorosa e difícil não só
para quem está a sofrer mas para também
para aqueles que tentam ajudar e em
terceiro lugar a compaixão envolve o
compromisso o compromisso para fazer é
que o que estava ao nosso alcance para
tentar aliviar o primeiro sofrimento que
narram um monge budista é muito
conhecido hoje em dia
descrita é compaixão é um verbo
apontando para a importância da ação
como porta com paixão e estação não
implica necessariamente fazemos coisas
religiosas e heróicas por nós e pelos
outros
implica muitas vezes os cintos
simplesmente ser solidários encorajador
de que estava isso os silos capazes de
enfrentar os nossos medos com
amabilidade com força ou ajudar outras
pessoas a enfrentar os tempos
às vezes podem implicar aprendemos a
sermos pessoas mais ativas e dizemos que
não na hora certa
às vezes ser compatível apenas fazer o
pequeno por nós e pelos outros ou às
vezes é simplesmente saber o que fazer
numa determinada situação e não ter medo
de fazer e facto as investigações
ao longo dessas últimas duas décadas
mostram que a compaixão tem múltiplos
benefícios para o nosso bem estar para a
nossa saúde mental para a forma como nós
mudamos as nossas emoções é para a forma
como nos relacionamos com as outras
pessoas inclusivamente para a nossa
física e dados de um estudo recente por
exemplo que nós fizemos com os concertos
aqui na universidade e mostram como a
intervenção breve cada na compaixão é
capaz de melhorar o bem estar das
pessoas aumentará sua capacidade para
serem competitivas em relação a elas
mesmas em relação aos outros e é também
capaz de diminuir o seu autoritarismo
são a cidade e os seus trés e não só
este impacto teve no seu bem-estar ou
seja estas variáveis mais psicológicas
já em termos fisiológicos no nosso corpo
porque o que aconteceu nesta
investigação foi cansando perceber que
os nossos participantes é aumentavam e
melhoravam a forma como seu corpo
responde e fisiologicamente ao stress e
nós vimos isto porque no final da
intervenção os participantes melhoraram
é veremos naquele dia que o indicador
fisiológico é nossa resposta adaptativa
aos 3 enquanto ser sonante assim a e
aproximando do do concluir nesta desta
partilha de ideias aqui convosco hoje
nós humanos
é com este cérebro que é capaz das
coisas mais maravilhosas mas também das
mais vis crueldade
numa sociedade cada vez mais competitiva
individualista e materialista e focada
no prazer imediato onde a solidão e os
problemas de saúde mental são cada vez
mais prevalente no mundo afligido por
guerras fome conflitos sociais mudanças
climáticas extinção de espécies
hoje mais do que nunca nós precisamos de
uma função da compaixão porque cultivar
com paixão pode de fato revolucionado a
forma como nós lidamos com o nosso
sofrimento e com o sofrimento dos outros
à nossa volta
cultivar com paixão pode ajudar-nos a
tornar um dos seres humanos mais
despertos para a nossa humanidade comum
para a natureza complexa da nossa meta
pode ajudar nos a não só a promovermos o
nosso conhecimento enquanto pessoas e
ferimentos a nossa volta mas trabalha
construirmos um mundo mais solidário
mais consciente e mais acolhedor para
todos os que nela habitam e eu acredito
que a compaixão é o nosso super poder
humano cujo orçamento se existem dentro
de todos nós e que todos nós podemos
cultivado
todos nós podemos aprender a sermos mais
sensíveis ao sofrimento e à nossa volta
e nós mesmos e em sermos capazes de
desenvolver a sabedoria é coragem ea
força para lidar com que é difícil
as vendas se algum dia mais voltaram a
aplicar fé em londres é que o caso desta
vez eu vou escrever aparelho será ser
compassiva comigo mesmo e com os outros
da minha volta e sobretudo nos momentos
de maior dificuldade e por isso meu
desejo para hoje aqui e para toda a
humanidade é que todos nós possamos nas
nossas vidas na nossa relação conosco e
construção próximo mas também na relação
com aqueles que ignorante ou que
desconhecemos na relação com aqueles
quem não constante ou com quem temos
conflitos na nossa relação com todos os
outros serviços deste planeta que é
nossa casa a terra que sejamos capazes
de despertar este super poder humano que
é compaixão de reconhecer que ele existe
dentro de todos nós e com sabedoria
coragem e um profundo compromisso
consigamos pôr em marcha é a evolução da
compaixão capazes não só nos tornar
seres humanos mais fluência
mas talvez mesmo salvar a evolução da
nossa maneira
obrigada
[Aplausos]